[Musica]
alla fine degli anni ottanta dan simmons
scrittore di fantascienza americano
pubblica questo meraviglioso appaga in
quattro volumi i canti di hyperion
una degli escamotage narrativi su cui si
basa questo racconto e la possibilità di
viaggiare attraverso infiniti mondi
attraverso il tele porter che non è
altro che il teletrasporto e gran parte
del fascino di questa storia è proprio
scoprire mondi immaginati da dan simmons
ci sono anche altri modi meno divertenti
di viaggiare nel mondo di endimione
firjan scoprirete se lo leggerete tra
l'altro è stato da poco ripubblicato ma
il teleporto è proprio facile come
andare da una stanza all'altra
infatti nel prezzo del libro che ho
scelto per voi per iniziare racconta che
mio zio martin aveva una casa tele
porter le distanze esistevano su decine
di pianeti diversi
io avrei subito una stanza sul mare una
stanza sulla montagna e una milano e
ovviamente ciascuno di noi sognerebbe ma
ovviamente c'è qualcosa che non va
nelle storie per chi racconta storie per
chi come me usare storia per lavorare
non può andare tutto liscio perché se va
tutto riesce una storia e noiosa non è
una storia interessante non funziona non
ci viene voglia di andare avanti e
quindi andando secoli dopo sempre nella
saga si ricordano ancora dei tele porter
che non ci sono più sono stati chiusi è
il protagonista di se i tele porter
erano operati dalle intelligenze
artificiali del tecnico cleo secondo la
chiesa e canti di tuo zio martin erano
una sorta di trucco delle intelligenze
artificiali per usare i cervelli umani
ecco nelle storie l'escamotage narrativo
per far avanzare il meccanismo che ci
porta a voler girare le pagine a vedere
ancora un'altra puntata è un meccanismo
narrativo
il problema con le storie soprattutto
della fantascienza ma non solo e che
negli ultimi anni teniamo a prenderlo un
po troppo sul serio e io sono sicura che
tutti voi quando pensate alle
intelligenze artificiali che usano i
cervelli umani non pensate alla fine
degli anni 80 e al mondo di e piria
ma pensate a internet ai social media
abbiamo rotto internet ok non è
esattamente la internet che sognavo da
bambina e quasi ci sono arrivata che
ancora lo ero ma volevo invitarvi
accompagnarvi in questi dieci minuti a
pensare che ci piace un po troppo aver
paura della tecnologia ci caschiamo
troppo facilmente una paura troppo bella
troppo sugosa che attira subito la
nostra attenzione se dobbiamo scegliere
di cosa aver paura del co2 del
riscaldamento climatico di rendere il
nostro pianeta inabitabile o dei social
media
noi abbiamo più paura dei social media
sia una cena voi parlate del
riscaldamento climatico
la conversazione si inabissa se una cena
voi parlate dell'abuso dei dati fatto da
facebook o da chi volete voi le persone
si scaldano gli animi montano
abbiamo un sacco di voglia di aver paura
della tecnologia che usiamo e in più
oltre ad averla questa stranezza no io
personalmente sono più terrorizzato dal
riscaldamento climatico ci piace
moltissimo mettere questa situazione
diciamo questo pericolo possibile che
esiste in entrambi i casi sotto forma di
dilemma ecco il dilemma è una dicotomia
una dicotomia e binaria una delle accuse
che spesso viene fatta al computer
quello di essere binario ma nella mia
esperienza della mia vita nella mia
giornata molto spesso binari siamo noi
umani perché ragioniamo sempre in
termini di internet si internet no
aprirla chiuderla libera censurata non
pensiamo mai a tantissime altre
possibilità che ci sono i dilemmi
dilaniano
di là mi sono dolorose di lenny
strappano allora pensando a un panorama
che amo molto più quello di camogli dei
pescatori che ricuciono le reti mi sono
chiesta ma se invece di farci dilaniare
dai dilemmi invece di strappare
iniziassimo a ricucire
perché la rete che una rete dove
finiscono impiegate tante cose sempre
pensando anche al riscaldamento
climatico nelle reti dei pescatori
finiscono tante cose che ci buttiamo
dentro noi che sono un po più pericolose
delle scorie che buttiamo nella rete
digitale ma non ci fa paura quello
pensiamo raramente ma le reti comunque
la rete internet ma non solo anche la
rete di amici la rete di colleghi le
reti di parenti le reti sono ovunque
intorno a noi sono fatte da noi
non è arrivata l'intelligenza
artificiale di hyperion a costringerci a
fare qualcosa quella è una storia è una
bellissima storia molto interessante ma
non è la verità
la verità è che siamo noi che incagliano
nella rete il bello e il brutto ma è
sempre una produzione umana di emozioni
umane
di the umane di pensieri umani di
contenuti umani allora io mi chiedo
perché abbiamo così tanta voglia e così
tanta fretta di rinunciare a tutto
questo perché la prima cosa a cui
pensiamo è chiude riuscire disinstallare
cancellare cancellarci perché non ci
prendiamo cura di questa rete allora vi
invito a cominciare a pensare a che cosa
fate che cosa vi viene spontaneo fare
quando qualcosa a cui tenete si rompe di
saletto proviamo ad aggiustarla non la
buttiamo via subito c'è anche una
spiegazione biologica
io sono molto affascinata come tanti dal
lavoro dalle riflessioni di stefano
mancuso su tutto quello che abbiamo da
imparare dalle piante
ecco mancuso disse che le piante hanno
delle caratteristiche molto interessanti
perché non possono scappare
la pianta sta lì c'è qualche pianta si
muove ma diciamo che di norma le piante
soprattutto quelle le mie sul mio
terrazzo poverina non posso fare e
vorrebbero secondo me farlo ma non
potendo scappare le piante fanno il
meglio con quello che hanno
noi animali in quanto c'è un pericolo
scappiamo e la facciamo da millenni noi
uomini siamo animali credo di non
rivelare niente di stravolgente ma
questo percepire un mutamento percepire
un problema è battercela alla velocità
della luce diciamo che nel percorso
evolutivo potremmo anche cominciare a
fermarsi ogni tanto un attimo e dire ma
perché io devo scappare da internet solo
perché si è rotta solo perché è piena di
roba che non mi piace solo perché non
funziona come dovrebbe
perché non iniziò a pensare di ripararla
di questo gesto di rammendare di
ricucire di riparare di integrare di
stanare di curare un gesto profondamente
umano ma soprattutto quando noi pensiamo
di evitare qualcosa di scappare quindi
da internet e di evitare problemi della
rete e dobbiamo sempre ricordarci che
esse noi disinstalliamo internet e vi
riporto al mondo di ripi rione a un
certo punto i tele porter chiusi quindi
tu in cucina sul mare non ci vai più è
il tuo migliore amico che abitava al di
là della teleport più vicino non lo puoi
più vedere perché a distanza di anni
luce e non vi racconto come si viaggiava
senza tele porter nel mondo riempire un
perché è un po sanguinolento quindi nel
momento in cui noi siamo così veloci nel
dire basta chiudiamo la mi cancello me
ne vado che schifo voglio una vita vera
preferisco vedere gli amici al bar a
tutte le cose che sento dire tutti i
giorni
dimentichiamo che nella rete ci sono
tante cose
di un enorme valore
una delle prime questa ok il tris è una
rete né una rete di volontari una rete
di contenuti e una rete di
idee e di una rete resa possibile anche
grazie alla rete internet è nata prima
non è necessario che ci sia ma l'enorme
scambio di idee penso alla ricerca penso
comunque tutto il lavoro intellettuale
reso possibile dalla facilità di
contatto con la rete è un qualcosa a cui
sinceramente non me la sento di
rinunciare solo perché all istinto di
fuga perché qualcosa non è esattamente
come me l'aspettavo
evitare problemi della rete vuol dire
anche sottrarre a noi introversi anno i
timidi io lo so che di solito le persone
sorridono quando dico questa cosa che so
di non sembrare una persona estremamente
timida ed estremamente riservata la rete
a me ha salvato la vita perché io
funziona meglio scrivendo comunico
meglio scrivendo comunico meglio
pensando a quello che ho da dire come
racconta molto bene questo libro quiet
uscito nella cultura come quella
americana dove se se introverso
sostanzialmente non esisti e con la rete
una grandissima risorsa per le persone
introverse che non è che non hanno
piacere a stare con altri astri umani ma
ogni tanto piacere anche stare un po da
soli ma non da soli la sfera solitudine
sgradevole da soli circondati da idee
stimoli emozioni video da un amico a
portata di whatsapp di click
evitare problemi della rete chiudere la
rete senza ripararla senza prenderci
cura di questo tessuto significa anche
rinunciare a una forma di solidarietà
che io aimo sperimentato troppe volte
nella mia vita dico troppe perché la
solidarietà di solito legata ai lutti
soprattutto i lutti improvvisi
ma quando c'è un lutto in una rete di
amici che si sono conosciuti online la
velocità di reazione la raccolta
immediata di soldi per aiutare chi ha
avuto un improvviso è letteralmente non
sa come fare andare avanti è
commovente non c'è un'altra parola
l'ultimo esempio di porto e spero che
sia l'ultimo per tantissimo tempo e
quando quest'estate si è perso in
montagna federico quando federico si è
perso in montagna elena la moglie non si
è rassegnata non ha voluto subire i
tempi delle ricerche che sono tempi
brevi perché i fondi sono pochi ha
portato centinaia di volontari in
montagna ha raccolto migliaia di euro
non è una storia che finisce bene perché
hanno trovato un corpo non hanno trovato
federico vivo ma per chiunque anche per
chi fosse a immaginare cosa vuol dire un
disperso trovare un corpo è meglio di
non trovare nulla e ha dimostrato la
potenza di questo strumento perché non
sono arrivati sono arrivati solo i loro
amici ma sono arrivati persone da tutta
italia solo per aiutare quindi
ricordiamocelo quando vogliamo evitare
qualcosa quando vogliamo disinstallare
qualcosa perché stiamo dicendo no a
questo stiamo dicendo no a noi perché
social media siamo noi ci stiamo auto
proponendo di chiuderci di eliminare
degli spazi che abbiamo
rammendare la rete invece vuol dire
usarla per costruire vuol dire usarla
per costruire non per distruggere vuol
dire tornare a un concetto antico ma
prezioso che line salamon violenza né
yoga sutra pad angiari dice che la
nonviolenza alla capacità di trasformare
l'ambiente che circonda chi la pratica
sono millenni che lo sappiamo
facciamolo è chiaramente chi progetta e
gestisce internet ci si arricchisce ha
delle responsabilità ma non tutte quelle
che noi amiamo pensare perché molto
facile dimenticare che siamo noi che
pubblichiamo in rete sotto quello che
c'è e quindi la rete siamo noi solo noi
potremmo ripararla la rete siete anche
voi che volete chiuderla e io canto da
vent'anni con i 99 posse non mi avrete
mai come volete voi non mi avrete mai
aggressiva paternalista saputella
pessimista cinica cometa che sia meglio
chiudere e aprire che non sia possibile
riparare una cosa che si è rotta essere
sovversivi oggi significa prendersi cura
gli uni degli altri e per chi conosce la
canzone 99 poste cantavano sta a votare
sovvertire io canto
rammendare ricucire e sono anche stonata
ma non me ne frega niente
insomma niente inevitabile non
facciamoci
intortare da questa idea che tanto ormai
in rete circola solo rumore e
aggressività e violenza
il futuro non è scritto nella pietra chi
ricorda heroes questa serie di un po di
tempo fa diceva state cheerleaders save
the world
quindi vi dico salviamo internet
salviamo il mondo è facciamolo insieme
[Applauso]